now by the shadow leveling up secretary
lisa nandy representing the opposition
this morning um story's not going
anywhere is it no i don't think it is
and the desperate thing about it is that
the more that this goes on
the less the government is able to focus
on what's actually happening to people
around the country boris johnson could
end this today he could come to the
house of commons he could come clean
about what has been going on in downing
street on his watch and his involvement
in breaking the rules that he made and
then we could focus on the crisis that
is unfolding right across this country
people don't know how they're going to
keep their heads above water with that
triple whammy of shopping bills going up
energy bills going up and the tax hike
that's about to hit people in a few
months time i want to talk about
leveling up in a second but another
couple of things that we did speak to
your counterpart about and that includes
what was said at the dispatch box about
jimmy savile
um and we had the leader your boss sat
there just yesterday was furious about
it prime minister seems to have doubled
down in an article in the sun this
morning i'm absolutely disgusted by what
we saw unfold
from boris johnson this week i used to
work with children and young people
before i came into parliament many of
them who'd been abused themselves and
the idea that you would throw lies and
mud around in the hope that it will
deflect from your own behavior and your
own political problems and use child
abuse victims and survivors as pawns in
that game i think this is a new low that
we've seen from the prime minister and
something that i never would have
expected to see from the prime minister
of the united kingdom we got the
impression uh from mr gove that lindsey
hole was wrong the speaker of the house
when he was suggesting that there was a
case to answer there i mean i that you
know i've i've known kirsten a long time
and when he was director of public
prosecutions not in charge of this
decision not the reviewing lawyer in
this case and not involved in it at all
i went to see him because i was working
with traffic children and i went to see
him to say these children who are
victims of abuse but are often being
picked up and prosecuted for offenses he
saw me at a time when many many doors in
power were closed to us and made sure
that they brought in new guidelines in
order to try and change that for those
children i can tell you right now that
there are some politicians in this
country including kierstarma who have
been trying to help people
who've been who've been abused as
children there are other people like
boris johnson who are disgracefully
trying to use people survivors of child
abuse as political pawns i don't think
he's fit to hold office i've never said
that about a prime minister in my
lifetime but i think it's absolutely
clear from what we saw this week and the
way in which he's doubled down that that
is the case as far as ppe is concerned a
lot of the papers this morning carrying
the story that billions of pounds was
wasted on ppe i put that to mr gove and
he said some of it can be dismissed as
an accounting area i mean i just find
this extraordinary he's just published a
white paper on leveling up the plans
that we've been waiting for for two and
a half years
that have no new money behind them and
yet the government is writing off
billions of pounds in fraud and they've
wasted billions of pounds on ppe he's he
thought it wasn't a waste because um it
can be an accounting error and also we
needed it at the time i mean total
overpriced tell that to communities
across this country who have watched
money being stripped out of our towns
for the last decade that has been
turbocharged in the last three years
since this prime minister took office
you were reporting your reporter was
reporting from wolverhampton today the
amount of cash the refund that is being
given to wolverhampton
is far outweighed by the amount of money
they've lost even since the prime
minister took office and yet you have a
secretary of state who's responsible for
this agenda who can casually sit here
and dismiss eight billion pounds as an
accounting error i just think that's it
he didn't say all of it was an
accounting error but he said some of it
could be put down i mean
the way in which the government is so
dismissive about these things you know
the four billion that the chancellor
wrote off in fraud just a few days ago
that money could be put to such use in
our towns and cities across the north of
england we could see good jobs created
back in places that have seen them
depart for decades and yet the prime
minister just sits and dismisses
that as
a necessary unnecessary expense numbers
on a spreadsheet these are not numbers
on a spreadsheet this is our money and
we want it back
this is what i think we've got the grab
from michael gove haven't we a little
bit earlier this is what he was saying
i'm not going to apologize for the fact
that we moved heaven and earth to get
all the ppe that people on the front
line needed now some of those figures
are
accountancy markdowns the relationship
seven billion no yes some of it is
because of accountancy
well the key thing here is that uh the
uh the price that we paid for ppe at the
height of the pandemic is greater than
the cost now and that is because
everyone was in a global race to find
out a lot of it was rubbish and you
couldn't use it no um more than 97 of it
was absolutely right
i mean i think this just goes to the
heart of the problem you've got this
these announcements today that are
supposed to be putting power back into
our hands locally but actually as doing
exactly what this government has done
for a decade which is taking power back
to the center meanwhile at the time that
michael gove is talking about you had
local councils you had public health
providers ringing around procuring their
own ppe because the government system
was in complete and utter chaos had care
home workers buying things off amazon to
try to deal with the crisis that was
unfolding and the government just wasn't
stepping up and now we've got this
this series of excuses this string of
excuses about these contracts that have
been handed out often to their mates
who've made great profits through this
pandemic when people had to step up and
do this themselves i think michael gove
should just listen to himself
and reflect on the fact that we did step
up in many parts of this country when
the government didn't give us powers
back to actually deliver things for
ourselves and we will show you what can
be done they're trying to do that by
leveling up and and spending money
around the country they're trying
i mean
you know i think michael gove has been
trying actually he's been running around
whitehall for the last few months
desperately trying to cobble together
some announcements to put into this
white paper but having seen the white
paper it was leaked to me last night and
spent the night going through it what
we've got is a series of rehashed
announcements some of which are so old
they were actually originally made by
gordon brown when he was the labour
prime minister in 2008 this just simply
isn't good enough we need good jobs back
in our towns with good wages we need
money back into people's pockets so that
people can spend on our high streets and
our town centres can thrive again so
that young people don't have to get out
in order to get on and instead what
we've got is these these big slogans and
absolutely nothing behind it not just no
new money but no new powers either he's
going to have a dialogue with the
northern mayors about whether new powers
are needed we've told him they're needed
give us the power to drive that change
in our communities ourselves and we will
show you what we can do you say no new
money but as he pointed out there was a
shed load of money earmarked by the
chancellor and he's just telling us how
it's going to be spent now so that money
is money that is earmarked every year
and it's just been allocated in this
white paper to the same places that
would normally get it this is rehashed
recently
and well it's it's not actually i mean i
wish it was kay this is personal to me i
have skin in the game as you know being
a wig and girl yourself this is not just
about people voters this is about my
friends my family my neighbours my
constituents it's about whether we
places like wigan that within living
memory once powered this country and
built our wealth and influence can do so
again and i've seen what that looks like
i was in grimsby with kierstarma last
week meeting young apprentices who are
powering the world through the
renewables industry it puts money back
into people's pockets it makes our town
centres thrive again and instead what
we've got is a hundred page essay
celebrating the glories of the roman
empire and the medici style renaissance
that michael gove wants to see across
the country i mean this is just nonsense
people will see that this is a
government in free fall it has all the
hallmarks
of a government that is out of energy
and ideas we were promised a lot but
getting absolutely nothing to show for
it former shadow foreign secretary are
the government on the right tack when it
comes to ukraine i think that they are i
think it's absolutely right to say that
we will stand up to russian aggression
and that we will stand with nato and
with our allies including ukraine in
doing so i think we should be far more
focused on cleaning up the dirty money
that flows into the city of london
that's something that we've been urging
the government to do for several years
now since the russia report was
published 21 recommendations in that
report not a single one yet implemented
in full the government needs to take
that seriously if they're going to be
taken seriously in moscow but we
absolutely stand together as a country
against president putin and russian
aggression it will not stand okay
looking forward to prime minister's
question i mean i never look forward to
prime minister's questions i absolutely
love the thing and no but i mean just i
think people look at it and just think
what are you all doing i mean you know
we've got a prime minister who won't
tell the truth he obfuscates he won't
answer the question and most people
around this country are just absolutely
desperate to know why are you hiking up
my taxes why aren't you doing anything
about these massive energy bills how am
i going to keep my head above water and
why have we got after two and a half
years these plans for leveling up the
country that amount to nothing more than
hillary beans beans
i organized the lighting cherry and
white just for you
thank you very much if you're from wigan
you know if you don't you don't wiggle
warriors everybody the right type of
room there you go it's good to talk to
you thanks very much thank you